spécialisée dans la réalisation des
écrans de cinéma l'entreprise des mots
spec d'amis a rappelé tous ses salariés
depuis l'annnonce de la réouverture des
salles de cinéma le carnet de commandes
s'emballe avant c'était très calme et
depuis l'annnonce on n'arrête pas
d'avoir des demandes et tout est pour
demain à nous demander des cotations
pour des écrans extérieurs pas mal donc
je pense que ça ça va ça va s'exposer
quand même avec la période d'été et où
on a des grands et croma des 20 mètres
par 10 mètres de haut
des clients qui ne commandaient jamais
ce genre de choses
maintenant on nous demande des écrans
extérieurs aux premières loges pour
sentir la reprise d'activité les 26
salariés passent du chômage partiel au
plein régime de production soit 15
écrans de projection par jour des délais
très courts cdd les très courts alors il
y avait quelques projets qui étaient en
attente et maintenant les cinémas les
exploitants veulent changer la toile
avant le 19 mai puisque même avec 35 %
ils vont pouvoir ouvrir le 19 mai donc
là il se hisse énerve tout ça ils
veulent tous tous leurs écrans tout de
suite c'est de cette usine du loiret que
partent les écrans des cinémas de toute
l'europe
en année normale c'est 7 millions de
chiffre d'affaires si la reprise est là
il faut qu'elle tienne on voit tellement
un changement par rapport à la semaine
dernière
on n'ose pas espérer qu'on soit revenue
tout de suite à la normale d'avant du
monde d'avant donc on a peur que ça soit
un one shot et puis après ça serait
souffle et souffle un petit peu comme
quoi la culture cinématographique est
aussi essentiel à l'économie